okay Isis is trying to FaceTime decline
FaceTime message info
well hello reject nation
Craig John Humphrey Rene yeah they're
committing guys 13 times I've got caught
lying on social media this is from
clever news clever news does a lot of
great list videos that I personally love
watching and I found out today that Rene
is part of clever TV and clever news and
I was like dude can we watch a list
video together cuz I love their list
videos and now we hear yeah I get your
commentaries I know my the scenes and I
do heard the Rossum video you are clever
I could just look at you exactly listen
can you bring in one of these narrate
alive here we go guys 13 celebs got
caught lying on social media I have
never lied on social media I have I'm in
this video you're famous you know a
little bit to a couple people you know
to a couple people maybe I wonder if
strums on this list is he considered a
celebrity okay he's she knows and thanks
to the power of the screenshots that
line is forever immortalized
answer parent right here it may not
always be fun and games when it's a
lesbian I love them me otherwise but in
what was possibly the most recent and
hilarious life didn't disappoint
according to Bob while the line was
elaborate plan for promo for a show
growing up hip hop Atlanta doesn't be
ruffled trying thinking he got a new jet
the singer posted an instant well kinda
gets a new jet for Christmas and she
beautiful except it was a charter jet
they got him from Canada York and not a
gift some cash
he was lying when he said he was gifted
a Bugatti which also was against acute
pelvis over will get off PETA and every
other animal lover of March 2016 alright
very Jackie the caption devil is faux
fur but many readers heated TMZ pointed
out it was actually a very real why
would you lie Oh people will find out
even though Britney Spears is one of the
[Music]
[Music]
only yes that was a kitchen punch she
upload a photo of pie she allegedly
baked herself only problems three of
them are identical to pie made by
premier la bakery even though - she is
[Music]
to take thank you for the beautiful
memories Title II probably once you
believe she took it with man Thomas it
catching her the lie thing the pic was
one of the first results on Google but
perhaps the real question research back
didn't you
but it turns out of the tog refer closes
at two weeks earlier and call them out
in the comments you're filthy rich what
turns out they want you to believe
so the boy got dragged big time in 2014
proposes with fake stacks of cash well
we had a 100 dollar bill to top all the
paper underneath was a white computer
paper for a video and he was real I need
my supposed to be rich real about the
Trump location and then instakills
during a huge debate across country
about a blonde moment she upload the pic
endure that fashion brands fan she was
going on a date in NYC but Ivanka was
actually in California why her dad runs
in the family
in the end of the digital world I got
hacked is the new cry wolf take Rita Ora
she tweeted she'd relief let me make
none of us got 100 thousand retweets but
she managed to only get a little over a
thousand she says she was hacked if
someone was threatening to release new
music Lindsay Lohan is another celebrity
arena obvious Photoshop bill she tried
to enhance her booty but fail to realize
[Laughter]
[Music]
but which you mess with Kanye and Kim
things got bad every one of the biggest
and most infamous recent selecting
scandals Kim posted a snapchat video
Taylor giving honey the green light for
lyrics to his song famous that she had
been vocal about being upset after the
song was released on her life Taylor
took to Twitter to say she wanted to be
excluded from the narrative to try a
queen to blame at Kim and Kanye for
recording Devin earned the nickname
snake that seems like a good place to
leave off so now that we've counting
down this lapse we've got a hotline on
social media I want to know which one
had you cringing the most or if we miss
your faith let us know in the comments
section below
then click right over here to watch a
few rings where you live red carpet
interviews and as always don't forget to
Like subscribe
I'm your host abilities jr. thanks so
much for hanging out with me here on
clever as always you know I think well a
meal meal single a meal a single oh my
as time you might be he's got some
pretty big arms he's hot right pretty
sexy he works out for sure yeah yeah
that's the one thing I can tell the meal
if you're watching I'm gonna answer a
meals question the one that really stood
out to me really calm I got a photo shop
is always like what a horrible thing I
get how especially if you're celebrity I
feel like oftentimes if you're aspiring
to be like a famous actress or something
or model sometimes you do Photoshop
stuff and I get it and it sucks because
there's that pressure to be so sexy in
front of the camera
stuff John and I would know you probably
have no yeah we yeah you try to
understand you know well yeah you have
no idea this job is harder no idea I
don't know how you do it you don't know
the struggle alright same my abs are to
cut so I have to often give myself a
little bit of it like this is altered
right here yes video yeah I don't know I
mean you gotta be really careful with
that [ __ ] everything people will rip you
a new one if they catch you being at all
a little bit of a liar like there's this
mantle of being a celebrity what's your
President Trump if you're not lying one
bit then suddenly your reputation is
totally damaged man that's the one that
really stood out to me I'm just a silly
one to get God keep going crazy like
they'll find out everything like if you
post something and you have like like a
teeny tiny pin in the background the
zoom and zoom and read the pin find out
says one thing says you mean it like
it's crazy it's crazy it's crazy I'm
also crazy but like yeah I do it too we
all try to connect the dots the thing
that stood out to me most in this video
is like half of these were people taking
like stock pictures of stuff yeah their
own and the Britney one was the easiest
tell I was like that doesn't look like a
picture of you - yeah I think Britney
what were you thinking girl I love
there's someone out there who's like I
looked at a core on the car I think I've
seen this wonder cuz like they were but
like there's there was the Kim Thailand
picture that wasn't real and there's the
Diddy Eclipse picture that wasn't real
so now I'm sitting there going are these
just like they have their marketing team
doing the social media and being like oh
yeah find me a picture of something
that's kind of like what I'm doing today
or is it just oh I can't be late to this
experience we're all having together
have a picture I see such an easy
mistake to avoid I mean for sure but
here's the thing like for Kim's I don't
know if necessarily she was trying to
imply that she took that just saying
like Thailand's been real whatever
whereas Britney was like I couldn't look
at the core
or or Chloe that hold like these I as
I'm so proud of yes I rather like that
someone else baked those yeah it
surprises me how many celebrities try to
make themselves look richer than they
are I know like does it matter like I'm
for my style
other people out there who really care
about that like actual like just regular
people who follow famous people like we
care to know how rich you are feel like
you're super rich and I get it for
you're a rapper cuz rap isn't like
Soulja Boy or Bow Wow doing that kinda
thing I'm like I get that comes with
your reputation yeah but like Justin
Bieber even like bullshitting his way
onto a jet like come on man you don't
need to do that I was like maybe you're
not pitching this is this jet belongs to
me maybe it's just like oh they upgraded
the jet we're gonna travel to the jail
on Christmas I just don't know I
personally find it more appealing when a
celebrity just flies like on a regular
plank no I think it's more humble and
relatable cool experience I won't get to
have that's gonna use a bunch of
unnecessary gasoline yeah for you man
but I wish I was rich and famous enough
to even be able to lie about like like
if I tried pulling not know what no one
would believe me but like if you're
Justin Bieber people are gonna buy it I
baby that's the benefits of becoming
celebrities your lies have to get more
interest you can't just lie about normal
stuff yeah I did buy groceries it's like
no one cares I think my next 13
Instagram posts are gonna be me
replicating these exact photos right now
I'm going to start lying and really the
exact course
tonight oh look so good making asking
what was the Beyonce wine okay they
breezed through that for sure but she
was essentially doing the same thing
that Lindsey Lohan was with like
altering her body oh I wanted to see
more Beyonce that's my only complaint
god yeah it seems like the guys like to
look like they're richer yeah the girls
like to look like they're more fit yep
that seems to me the cliche of how it
goes down wow man I can't I want to be
famous well because I can have these
problems even interesting though with
like gender roles could you imagine the
responsible woman would get they were
posting like bragging imagine like Kim
Kardashian look at all like it's just
like guys like rappers can get away with
it but if women do the same thing it
wouldn't that's true regardless they're
lying or not oh my gosh if they were
lying on top of that the backlash let's
flip it around man let's get all the
hip-hop artists and dudes made my biceps
a bit bigger yeah also you know these
macaroons I made I just stole off a
company website these are great before
man this well which one stood out to you
the most the Britney Spears Britney
Spears oh that's hysterical I laughed I
think replay I think I loved the one
that the most was the one I like if I
don't if I get enough likes you earned a
hundred thousand she got like over a
thousand yeah and I was like I don't
like those are the ones that fascinate
me because I'm like this could be true
and this could just suck for you cuz no
one believes it right this is just very
embarrassing so sad oh man that was
great guys seriously clever TV and
clever news I really do like their list
but he has not seen plenty of them find
one of Renee's video I wonder Renee
she's Dutch you've written some
written written wrote wrote you wrote or
something actually yeah you want to look
up like celebs have been accused of
lip-syncing you might see a familiar
face
you mean featuring Game of Thrones is Ed
Sheeran what yes yes I guess who I saw
on the thumbnail but he is in the video
yeah he's also guys I subscribe to the
real rejects make sure to check out
clever TV and clever news Ricky catch
from nay
erielle on there as well patreon.com
slash the real rejects become a paste
Ron injected a dad John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram
renee Ariel on Twitter and Instagram
where she does not Photoshop right no I
do not does not Photoshop you don't do
it don't be Lindsay Lohan actually
should we should all get shirts to say
don't be Lindsay yeah
also her dating blog sexting in the city
I've read quite a bit of it it's really
funny stuff some great advice I
successfully landed a girlfriend in the
process of reading it and now she's
dumping me tonight so take care guys